this freak saying I'm here with Kevin
Hart and you got a movie coming out
stand up yes and it's called what now
where you perform for 50,000 people 53
it was fifty fifty thousand were
enjoying it three thousand there weren't
so many but you're being a dick okay
who loved it okay the first comedian to
ever perform in a football stadium so he
just says let me tell you the last thing
I'm sad coming attention now what I
really love about what I did is that it
hasn't been done concert film as many as
fifty one thousand for a second
good god this looks like a tuxedo from
the year three thousand fifteen what is
this and this is how you stand oh that's
Nike look what I'm doing pretty smart
Nike up here Reebok down
you don't karate kick at the SEC no you
don't get paid twice they have no idea
that you're wearing their product they
don't care I just got the broad out no
you Nike up here
Reebok down there these sneakers we
don't even know who made them they're
Romania my point is I get paid three
times I rent my whole ass when I did
that this is filling it blood right now
you are I see no difference in color see
color Kevin Wow such a high level of
white is so why you ever open a can of
spam and look at it
that's the scar I got when my mom made
me take out the trash and a tuna fish
can cut it to the bone
that should 78 now this one's ripped
stop you important this karate kicks
better than I love a pointless karate I
really do I've decided to go vegan no
here's my question
yeah we are we here are you actually
gonna do some working out you don't just
get this
[Applause]
I didn't know you wanted me to do that
many you sometimes wanted one I can't go
up that high and do that don't do that
don't do that cut yourself
No
okay that was pretty good I did
something you did something we work
together and it is 14 I thought
something you didn't feel that just done
got a little bit my hand okay why are
you so out of breath my body wants to
get buff woman but I don't want to scare
my fans you have the body of a Dutch
woman I just looked off camera and I see
that Kevin brings his own train do you
bring him in here look at this guy
this is your trainer yeah no blunder
meet my trainer get in here
this is Ruben
Zubin works me out twice a month and
then we go over my accounts what he also
does my taxes it's queer your methods of
working out are an attempt to kill me
it's not an attempt to keep this is a
neutral third party woman hello hello I
told you the Wardrobe plays a major part
in new jeans before we even get to the
training look at the top yes I guess I
could top but it's like oh hey I'm here
I think it says weird here what we'd
like to do is have you trained both of
us show us some moves maybe we don't
know anything you do I will have already
probably done it or seen it because I'm
well-versed as a man who did a concert
for 49,000 people that was in people I'm
giving you things that maybe you've seen
before maybe you've seen before maybe
you haven't whoa her head power today
you know what I like I like a dramatic
motivation for what I do so I'm gonna
pretend I was just given this ball for
Christmas yes and I didn't want a blue
rubber ball for Christmas to watch this
Kevin Christmas Christmas
I got something I'm about to perform but
it's just a little comedy club I don't
want to perform an old comedy club I
want to perform for $53 that was gonna
get your voice a little high do I that's
how you were talking just now his feet
his shoes are a lot dirtier than mine is
there any way to play yes I get a towel
yeah we're ready
that's like a beautician from the future
a ball of Macaulay Culkin no accurate
count for how many people
thank you like goddamn respect it's a
football stadium yeah pretty good what's
the customer got so far
Jack I'm not out of breath you seem a
little off
can we get old ass some water
hey I'll show you how to spar with Kevin
Hart
it's funny it's funny what do you do
you look like you wanted to kill me
that's not sure yes look into his eyes
look one way hit the other man although
your outfit but it's holding you back
it's constricting it's too tight you
look like you're on your way to a nice
Armenian wedding I have loose fabric and
rings whatever glass listen you push me
in the tail push me in the tickets
together with rings and my team I
motivated and inspired my friend to do
the unthinkable and that's to get up and
be active camera change and with that
being said of you his fans the people
that love him the most he can change and
become a better man camera change move
is hard
Temujin that's an infomercial
[Applause]
you